what's going on everybody I'm Warren
Thompson and welcome back to the cosmic
wonder your source for all things Marvel
and today we have some really exciting
reports about Mephisto and the MCU yes
he has been a meme for quite some time
now ever since one division one that
might not ever truly go away especially
if you consider the fact that many
outlets have been reporting that
Mephisto is making his way to the MCU
recently we've gotten some reports that
a Mephisto Disney plus special is in the
works right now over at Marvel Studios
and a report from deadlines suggested
that Borat himself the actor Sasha bear
Cohen is going to be playing Mephisto in
the MCU however some recent information
kind of hints that there could be a bit
of a Twist to this and that Sasha Bara
Cohen is not actually going to be
playing Mephisto now don't panic yet
we're not saying that there isn't going
to be Mephisto in the MCU and there
isn't going to be a project or Disney
plus special about Mephisto though but
rather the actor or actress is going to
be different because recently some
insiders online have hinted that Aubry
Plaza could actually be the one to play
Mephisto instead of Sasha barakoen and
if we take a look at the details of what
we know so far this actually makes sense
and we're gonna break it all down but
first if you are a big Marvel and DC
Comic fan I want to tell you all about
my buddies over at comicbookdirect.com
they have created a website and company
that makes comic book shopping the
easiest it can possibly be they deliver
Comics straight to your door you can get
one-off Comics or you can sign up for an
entire run and get a pretty big discount
if you do so and they'll ship the latest
issue right to your door each week they
have the latest from Marvel if you're
trying to keep up to date with all the
recent projects they have the latest
from DC as well and it's an all-in-one
shop for your Comics everything that you
need in one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below now what's really interesting
is that deadline did not actually
confirm that Sasha Baron Cohen was going
to be playing Mephisto they specifically
said a source close to the production
confirmed to deadline that there is talk
on the set about Cohen being a part of
the ironheart series likely playing
Mephisto now they drew this conclusion
because we had heard recently that
Mephisto was indeed going to be
appearing in multiple upcoming projects
ironheart being one of them Agatha
Covenant of chaos being one of them and
then we got a report about a Disney plus
special about Mephisto so it seemed like
this made the most sense at the time
however like I mentioned some insiders
recently reported that Aubry Plaza is
most likely playing Mephisto and she has
already confirmed to be a part of the
cast of Agatha coven of chaos which is
going to be about dark magic Witchcraft
and is just generally going going to be
a more darker Supernatural Project in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe The
Insider account can we get some toast
tweeted out a picture of Aubry Plaza in
a witch costume next to a picture of
Mephisto hinting that the actress could
be playing mephista which would mean and
I can already hear people complaining
but this would mean that mephista would
be gender swapped however if you have
seen Aubry Plaza in anything but
specifically shows like Parks and Rec
then you already knew that Aubry Plaza
playing a witch was pretty much perfect
casting but on top of that I have zero
doubt in my mind that she would make a
great Mephisto or a great demon now
Sasha Bara Cohen could be playing
another demon as well and he could be
the one that shows up in the ironheart
series it's been rumored that the hood
the main villain of the series is going
to kind of get his powers from a demon
and Sasha barakowen could very well be
that demon or if it's Aubry Plaza she
could show up in that show as well
asthma Fisto but here's some news that
kind of supports the fact that Aubry
Plaza could be Mephisto beside the
report from can we get some toast which
was also tweeted out by my time to shine
hello another Insider with a great track
record The Insider Jeff Snyder who has
had a good track record recently on the
hot mic podcast stated that a Marvel
Studios special presentation centered
around Mephisto is shooting right now on
the set of Agatha coven of chaos which
would make it super convenient for Aubry
Plaza Marvel Studios has kind of been
doing this lately and this seems to be
something that they're going to try and
be a regular thing with their shooting
schedules they did this with Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 3. they simultaneously
shot at the same time the Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special pretty much
using the same set or as much as they
could this seems to be what they are
doing with Agatha coven of chaos and
Mephisto and obviously there are huge
connections between Mephisto and Agatha
and also one division no we never saw
Mephisto but there were definitely some
hints in there but this does make it
extremely convenient for Aubry Plaza to
film Agatha coven of chaos and
potentially a Disney plus special where
she plays Mephisto now there is also
another report that makes us believe
that this could indeed be true when the
rumor got out about Sasha bear Cohen
right now filming his own Mephisto
Disney plus special on the set of Agatha
coven of chaos some people reached out
to Disney asking if it was true or not
Charles Murphy from Murphy's
multiverse.com was one of those people
who reached out I can confirm he is a
part of the press list for Disney and
when reaching out to Disney they stated
that the rumor about Sasha bear Cohen
filming a Marvel Studios special
presentation right now for Mephisto is
false now what's interesting is they
didn't say that a Mephisto Disney plus
special presentation coming is false
they simply said that Sasha bear Cohen
filming it right now that's false and
even though Sasha barakowen has been
spotted in other set location again that
doesn't necessarily mean he is going to
be playing Mephisto he could be playing
a demon and Aubry Plaza could be playing
the actual Mephisto and this could be
really interesting if she does end up
playing Mephisto because there are just
so many story lines that they can adapt
in the MCU that were great in the comics
I for one would love to see Aubry Plaza
interact with Benedict Cumberbatch as
Doctor Strange because doctor strange
and Mephisto have a lot of history
together in the comics plus not to
mention Dr Doom Dr Doom specifically the
story about his mother being taken to
befisto's realm hell is an incredible
awesome story and he even gets the help
of Doctor Strange to go into the hell
Dimension with him to try and get his
mother back from Mephisto and if you
know Aubry Plaza she can definitely play
a demon if not the demon the Mephisto
and in the infinity war comics not the
movies but the comics Mephisto even
played a very large role being basically
the right-hand man defend Thanos until
of course he tried to betray him but
Thanos was too strong at that point plus
not to mention there is word that a
special presentation for the Silver
Surfer is coming and that the Silver
Surfer will probably appear in the new
Fantastic Four movie well Mephisto loves
to try and torture and break the Silver
Surfer he has made tons of I should say
unsuccessful attempts to break the
Silver Surfer to break his will and his
soul plus not to mention Ghost Rider is
supposedly going to be in the MCU soon
as well he obviously has a very big
connection to Ghost Rider there as well
giving him his powers and really there
are just a ton of stories that they
could do with Mephisto in the MCU
because in the comics he has a lot of
connections a lot of stories with a lot
of different Heroes and some villains
and honestly either way this goes right
now if it's going to be Sasha barakoen
or Aubry Plaza I honestly think either
of them would be great for the role I
feel like Aubry Plaza's mephista would
be a little bit more sarcastic but as
long as they made her super menacing
when she had to kind of show the devil
that she is I'm okay with it but Sasha
bear Cohen would probably do a great job
as well so let us know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
please don't forget to like the video
also don't forget to comment and
subscribe to enter our giveaway we're
giving away some Marvel Legends items A
PS5 Xbox series X and some DC stuff as
well winner gets to choose when we
announce a winner at the end of the
month you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof